good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone had a splendid
wonderful rejuvenating monday i think
everyone did from what i was seeing
everyone seems to be splendid wonderful
and rejuvenating i think that we're
speaking for ourselves as well yes and
now it's a wonderful tuesday also known
as doozday because dukdaru was in the
building and i plan on larping with him
all show long so
if that bothers you
sorry i can't help it i know if you knew
do
then you wouldn't know what it's like to
lose yourself in a larp but you don't
larp i recently learned means oh did we
not talk about this on the main show we
talked about it on the patreon oh right
right right because someone like accused
me of larp of larping with the dogs and
so i said that to claudia because i
didn't really know what larping was and
she told me that it's live action role
play
and yeah no that's exactly what i do
isn't it nice to have a word now like
associated with who you are as a person
100
it's like clarity i feel seen
100 and you love to see it you do love
to see it
yes it was a rejuvenating day like i did
something i don't think i've done in
five years i slept the entire day my
body is just you understand i laid in
bed for two years straight and then i
had five back-to-back days with ten
thousand steps like that's just not how
i work yeah so my body's in shock and
when i got back from the toast yesterday
i have so much to do i passed out i
couldn't even keep my eyes open i was
just dead i still don't feel like 100
bounce back no i mean it takes time you
have to listen to your body i'm trying
keenly keenly and what was your body
saying
we're tired please stop moving
and i said man i understand i don't want
this any more than you do yeah so you
you took the time i feel like i actually
might sleep the whole day again today
like i know i sound dramatic for someone
who literally worked for five days but
it's so laborious on your body like the
traveling and then like the mental
anguish of like being in front of people
and then the actual doing stand up for
an hour like it's and then flying out
the next day like it was and then i also
went to a wedding like it's actually so
hard on your body so especially when
your body looks like mine so i'm very
much enjoying
this two-week period but this also was
just like the busiest week you know
everyone i know who like lives in l.a is
in new york i have like so many holiday
parties this week i'm just not ready
how nice for you so many parties i don't
mean parties parties parties no it is a
two-week grind over here and sometimes
self-care looks like sleeping in the
whole day i know you know and i just
feel i felt like i woke up i felt so
guilty like i had so many emails like i
didn't answer any of them i'm just like
i need a break like
well we have break coming up which is
going to be really nice so we just got
to rise and grind for the next two weeks
and we told everyone right our last show
of the year morning show season four
wraps it's december 17th so
yeah that's crazy whenever we like come
to the end of a year and we're like wrap
up our season it blows my mind that
we've been doing this for four years and
then two years before that
yeah like we're going in our fifth
season we're going into our fifth season
which is so exciting
i love a new season me too like i i have
like a new enthusiasm a new outlook
whenever i come back from a vacation
like i literally think i'm in a movie
like i'm a different person yeah i mean
you can be anyone that you want to be
that's so true
so and everything is just so festive
this time of year it's like even though
we're rising and we're grinding like
there's lights up on the trees like even
in the streets you know it's just a nice
time it is of year and the weather is
like today's really chilly port but it's
like it's been like gorgeously chilly
for the last few weeks chili yum oh
it might be a chilly day i need a break
from chili yeah i was making i was going
too hard too often and even though a
chili sounds delicious right now i can't
deal with a fridge full of chili again i
fully understand here i fully chili
maybe i should try something else
or a new chili recipe i know
chili's just so [ __ ] good
you should make a chili for me and i
should make a chili for you that way we
have like
well the thing is like i don't really
make chili ben does yeah the one time i
made it like you told me exactly what to
do over face it's just like i just want
a bowl of chili not a [ __ ] veggie
yeah no but like once you make it like
you got to make leftovers of course
what's the point no totally that's the
beauty of a chili chili is low-key toxic
like such a vicious cycle
it is um we have an amazing show because
it's tuesday which means we have deer
toasters in addition to the gorgeous
fast five stories that you need to know
um
and i'm ready to just like change
people's lives with our advice i really
am i am too and i'm ready to dive right
in because we have a lot to talk about
there's one story in particular that um
we should have been mentioned yesterday
but i guess i'm just you know blocking
it out
um we'll know what it when i when we say
it and so i think without further ado we
could jump right in i don't have any
other life updates other than just
enjoying the rose code other than the
fact that you're pregnant and can't do
anything right i was reading all day
yesterday and
the book is really good so thank you to
everyone who recommended it i'm glad
without further ado it is time for the
fast time stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the hydro jog seriously one of our new
favorite items these durable and
reusable jugs hold more than half a
gallon of water so you can stay hydrated
all day so we love the hydro jug because
it holds half a gallon of water it has a
leak-proof seal a wide mouth opening
which makes it super easy to add ice or
fruit it also has a carry loop which is
another option just to carry it easily
it's dishwasher safe bpa free and it's
shatter proof
it's a fabulous bottle all these like
cool celebs influencers are like
obsessed with their hydro jugs so if you
want to stay hydrated but also be cool
with a really cute water bottle check
out the hydro jug
it makes the perfect holiday gift
yes it does
um because there's a color for everyone
it's affordable and everyone needs a
water bottle give the gift of hydration
this year it's perfect for anyone on
your list so if you need some new gift
ideas the hydro drug will be perfect for
anyone on your list
and of course we have a code so it's
already affordable but if you go to get
um get your hydro jog at the hydro
jug.com use the discount code toast for
10 you're off your order today hydro
drugs are game changers for anyone on
the go and again you can use code toast
at the hydro jug.com to get 10 off today
and start hydrating
love it okay our first story some sad
news that emerged this weekend but i
want to break it down with you guys and
let you know that it's going to be okay
little mix is taking a break i know
so little mix put out a statement like
out of nowhere nobody asked for this
nobody was questioning anything nobody
was worried about them and all of a
sudden they said we wanted to let you
all know that after the confetti tour in
april may next year we are going to be
taking a break from little mix it's been
10 amazing years a wonderful non-stop
adventure and we feel the time is right
to take a break so we can recharge and
work on some other projects we can't
thank you enough for your love and never
ending support since the beginning we
love you all so much we are not
splitting up little mix is here to stay
we have plans for more music tours and
performances in the future we've made so
many incredible memories with you all
and we can't wait to make so many more
we're sisters and we'll always have each
other and you the fans in our lives
little mixes forever see you on tour
jade leanne and perry okay i think we
should break this down for a multitude
of reasons first of all i do like that
they said we're not breaking up
but there's some other worrisome facts
in this like we want to pursue other
projects that means like maybe one of
them has a lot of success with a solo
queer and doesn't want to come back even
though she intends to right now yeah it
sounds like a the one direction hiatus
they're still technically on hiatus okay
and that was after a member left i know
it definitely feels like it's mirroring
one direction but i'm gonna give you
mixers all the reasons why we shouldn't
panic yet first of all they did say that
they're not splitting up second of all
two of the ladies are new moms so like
of course they need a break the only
thing that's weird to me is like why
can't they just take a break without
announcing that they're taking yeah the
announcement makes it feel weird plenty
of artists don't put out music for years
at a time i don't know
so the announcement is weird because
like i would hope that the ladies wanted
to take time off and when it comes to
solo projects i don't think that that's
why they're taking a break because i do
think that for the new moms like they're
trying to work less not more and like
yeah why would you want to start like
building up a whole new solo career when
you have a great thing joey does
yes and maybe she'll do like she'll be
on some songs while the other girls are
home and and that works for me
but i think i really really truly
believe that like they love each other i
think they love being little mixed i
don't feel like it's a fifth harmony or
one direction situation where there is
one person who's always been waiting to
be a solo artist no i completely agree
these three they're
they're in harmony together
if you if i had to
say who would have the biggest solo
career out of the three that are left i
really wouldn't know i mean if i had to
say i might say perry only because of
all the zane stuff in my opinion she's
the most famous one at least in america
okay but like is she the most talented
no together i agree better together
they're really one-third
they all pull their weight and with
jessie leaving and like going on her
solo career like i don't think that it's
tempting them to do the same i don't
think it's going it's a flop central and
nobody wants to be that right so i
believe we have every reason
to be hopeful to be optimistic i think
that they will come back and other
projects could also mean like movies you
know so i'm not
i would i would be more alarmed if they
didn't take a break after like 10 years
of bangers and now two kids yes i agree
i'm not that worried
but just if history has taught us
anything it's not to be we're not
totally unclear no but like
everything about the messaging even like
their new song between us is about them
as a band like nothing comes between us
and it's such a good song and they use
that as the
soundtrack for the video that they
posted and then they sang it on the
graham norton show and they were all
like crying and hugging at the end like
i
crying and hugging does not bode well no
because they're gonna because they love
it they love it so much they were like
i'm i feel good about little mix and
also like
i could use a break from little mix like
they've been my top artist year after
year and like i can we could take a
break band yeah diversify the catalog
yeah i'm good with a break from them by
the way anyone who wants to take a break
an actual break like i will always
encourage mental health being in
spotlight is so taxing i
fully encourage people to take breaks we
should normalize taking more breaks
but break is often an euphemism even
when jessie first left the band she said
she was taking a mental health break and
we were like please go forth prosper and
then of course that's not what it was so
we we have been burned so many times
that we're just skeptical yeah i think
that's fair
but i
am not as skeptical as i could be
also
which is weird timing bts announced that
they're also taking a break but they
were like we're tired like they were
also very clear about what it is they're
like we're not bringing up like we're
exhausted why do bands feel the need to
let us know when they need to announce
when they're having a a break in between
albums like that's so normal right no
it's like your pto
yeah
no i agree it's always the announcement
that gives us like the willy nilly's 100
yeah so i i do feel like
some bands when someone leaves it tears
them apart like fifth harmony without
camilla cabello is just a bunch of i'm
sorry like except for normani average
performers like hanging out it's like a
cover band so that made sense when zayn
left one direction i think they were
better without him like i didn't think
they needed him to be what they were and
the same goes for jessie like i actually
think her leaving might have even made
the band better so i don't think it's
one of those situations where someone
leaves and it tears apart the whole band
like it did fifth harmony i just feel
like with one direction like you could
always feel them like bursting at the
seams like they don't want to be these
like boy banders teeny boppers you know
harry styles like is mick jagger and
he's gotta go do his own thing like that
feel natural but i feel like for little
mix like the band is really where they
are in their lives it's a reflection of
who they are i don't feel like they're
like putting on they're tied to the band
in a way that they hate yeah i agree and
that they're like you know it's they go
on stage and they have to pretend to be
people that they're not right i think
they get to be fully creative exactly
how they want to be the songs that they
want to make the songs they want to sing
i agree i think that they're creatively
fulfilled by the band whereas like one
direction they were just like
turning out hit after hit like they
didn't write that they didn't like hit
factory yeah of such good music such
good music but the best that i was ever
i think they were like embarrassed to be
performing it which is embarrassing for
them yeah i agree like you need to work
on yourself if you feel embarrassed by
some of those unbelievable hits
it was bop after pop after bob after bop
and i just
it it actually makes sense now that they
broke up because i banned that good
making
songs that were only better than the
next really it's not sustainable it
can't last forever so yeah that's not
even why they broke up they didn't even
i think they thought the songs were bad
no they thought their music was trash
and
and i think like as a society people
probably unless you're like a
directioner you're probably like oh one
direction boy bam they don't even know
they don't
the music that was made in those like
five years i think is some of the best
pop music to ever grace the earth
and i'm not being like dramatic i'm
being dead [ __ ] serious i totally
agree with you and i actually feel like
they're never going to come to that
conclusion because harry has had so much
success solo so
like really all of them have so they can
go actually
i would argue that only two of them have
zayn's solo career is flop central i
wasn't even thinking about zayn i'm
talking about the four who like lewis is
like
but he doesn't work for features
yeah no he doesn't i think and liam is
always like obviously some song on the
chart no
liam and lewis are like i think
irrelevant lewis is the most irrelevant
but i think he's tied for last with uh
liam liam
no liam is just like oh because i know
lewis has gone through a lot of personal
things in the last few years so the fact
that his career is not like number one
priority makes a lot of sense like he's
dealing with a lot
got it
okay well
whatever i think the worst of all the
solo careers has to be zane because he
tried just as hard as the rest of them
but failed the worst
really like that most recent album
pillows no no jackie that was like a
million years ago that was like right
after he left and he did some good [ __ ]
with with taylor
but then he put out this album most
recently he had like this van going
around new york city it was so sad it's
called like nobody's listening which was
so ironic because nobody was listening i
couldn't name one song off the album
it's like flop flop flop so i think of
all their solo careers like his was
probably the worst interesting but also
because he made the biggest stink about
it right
yeah
okay so oh sorry one more thing like
when we analyze the solo careers what i
didn't see coming from the solo careers
was like nile being really close to the
best one obviously no one beats harry
but niall's like way up there nile is
nothing to smirk about 100 it is i saw
him in concert he underratedly has so
many bops
he does i feel like he still shows up to
the hit factory and asks for music
you know what maybe he's the only one in
the man with any tastes behind you
he's like let me in i want i want back
at the hit factory his music is so good
yeah no i agree but it's very hit
factory right that's why it's good which
is why it's good
okay we'll let you know if little mix
you know gives us any more signals but i
would say for now mixers
remain calm no cause for alarm yeah
they've been through a lot as a band
yeah so i i i'm so here for it if it is
what it is if it is what it seems
our next story some fun comedy news
netflix announces a comedy festival
called netflix is a joke it will be an
11 day festival held in los angeles in
2022 where over 130 comedians will
perform a live festival or like on the
tv
like in person
in person like they're going to perform
at but it's also it kind of reminds me
of like new york city comedy festival
where it's just like comedy shows all
around town over the course of a month
that are just built under new york city
comedy there are a lot of comedy
festivals that like
are um
built as a festival but it's like
there's no unity they're just like a
bunch of random shows during the same
four weeks when i hear there's an eleven
day comedy festival i'm like oh my god
people are going to be sleeping in the
desert for 11 days right listening to
comedy
it's
like 25 hollywood landmarks such as the
greek theater the hollywood bowl dodger
stadium and the crypto.com arena oh my
god first comedy show at the crypto.com
arena we'll have all these comedians
including dave chappelle kevin hart
gabriel iglesias john mulaney amy
schumer ali wong amy poehler aziz ansari
chelsea handler chris rock conan o'brien
david letterman ellen degeneres enough
with david letterman i'm about to start
jerry seinfeld pete davidson ray romano
more that sounds very good like again
and i'm sure
they're filming it and it will be on
netflix yeah oh they'll be 11 specials
or however many people you just named um
25 i think you said 130 total oh maybe
not everyone's getting a special but um
i just maybe some are going to get like
to get like a variety yeah a variety
show i just want to
hark back to what i was saying about a
minute ago i've really had enough of
dave no david letterman
um i never found you funny and never
found you interesting and i just feel
like we've got to let let it go like
we're living in a different time and
david letterman's like random like loser
comedy i just don't think it's cutting
it anymore and like when you see all
these clips from his old show of how
evil he used to be like
i'm sorry why haven't you been canceled
yet yeah not i'm slowly becoming very
broken
no but it's like cancelled culture
should just it's selective and it
shouldn't be no yeah if it's gonna if
it's gonna exist which it does it's
roaring through town then everyone
should get all an evil footing yeah and
so david letterman like you are on my
list you need to be canceled especially
most egregiously because you're not
funny like you had kim kardashian for an
hour and you thought it would be funny
to take her to cbs like please no and
didn't ask her one new question that the
true fans haven't known the answer to
yeah and like thank god for her
ambulance talent and radiance for making
that hour so interesting because god
knows it wasn't the bearded lady david
letterman
yeah we know you're not about no
letterman life i just feel like he got
so famous i've said this before he got
so famous so successful i got the
biggest show on television in a time
where he was like one of three people
who was up for it like straight white
man like you're just not funny anymore
now that like everyone has a platform
you know with the internet and
everything yeah so that's what i feel
like and i'm the president of his hater
club like 100 no we know uh next time
i'll just skip over his name no it's
very triggering i don't know how many
times you can hear the david letterman
ran it's like enough like oh my god
everyone on that list like i love love
to see it yeah and i'm sure there'll be
a lot of like up and coming comedians if
it is 130 right you know and and they'll
be batched together so it could be a
great platform to discover new comedy
fabulous
but enough with the david levine
letterman okay okay so we won't be
watching that no but that sounds cool
it does it was supposed to happen last
year but then the pandemic because you
know it sounded familiar when you
started reading the headline yeah but
now it's here so if you you know happen
to catch any shows but it's also just
like going to a comedy show right i
don't think it's the type of festival
that you fly to it's like oh if you live
in la there happened to be a lot of
shows that want that month yeah no
exactly
but just they're under the unrelated
like of netflix yeah they're all related
to each other yeah no i have done two
comedy festivals
right one of them was minneapolis comedy
festival which i don't think is like
really got its legs yet and then i did
just for laughs which is a legit one and
i was very proud of that yeah exactly so
very exciting for the comedy world i
like that i like that netflix is taking
things irl
are you ready for our next story a
little clarification if it's a
clarification that's brought to you by
betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist where you'll be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours
help is not a crisis line it is not
self-help it is professional therapy
done securely online there's a broad
range of expertise available which may
not be locally available in many areas
here's how it works you log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist and you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do
with traditional therapy
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available because betterhelp wants you
to start living a happier life today
visit betterhelp.com
toast that's
betterhelp.comtoast and join the over 2
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using betterhelp that
they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states the special
offer for the morning toast listeners is
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
toast
great
now khloe kardashian is clarifying kylie
and travis's relationship status chloe
commented on a tick tock about the w
magazine spread
which the spread said that they were not
a couple under the sheets but they
haven't they are not a couple
chloe commented saying quote wow i don't
know why this magazine would write this
but they are very much a couple
this is the messiest
thing ever if because if you're on the
cover of a magazine and there's a whole
article inside about you that's because
you sat down with an interviewer and
they got all this information firsthand
from you so i'm very confused
it wasn't speculation by w magazine
because you sit down with
with a couple and they talk to you right
so did they make it up did kylie say it
i'm extremely confused i'm extremely
confused i can't believe like tmz was so
on the money this is just like another
point in tmz's column that it's like
okay i'm gonna give credence i'm gonna
refer to them on all things kardashian
at least yeah at least like the next
time
the whole thing is so i don't understand
it me neither
how do we get here i don't know
this is so messy like they really did
you know that they're together like
that's the takeaway here but
what the [ __ ] yeah
what like so an article that was
literally out for
two days is already irrelevant yeah no
this is so embarrassing for w magazine
yeah good for them no one's seeing it
they probably just put all these errors
in totally [ __ ] it um is it a story
about travis's
legal situation no so you know there's
all these lawsuits against him and his
official defense is like claiming
absolutely no responsibility for
anything that went on at the festival
and people are obviously really offended
by that yeah i guess it's like
a legal defense so he's just trying to
like
bear no legal responsibility but
obviously you are responsible yeah
that's but it just makes him look
even worse if we didn't think that was
possible yes and also in more legal news
jesse took the stand
yes and said that the two people said
this is back a country and today he's
being
cross-examined examined so hopefully you
know the real questions will be asked
and we'll have some updates tomorrow now
that is a court case i would be very
interested in sitting in on of course we
had to like watch him do all these
interviews like but it's also like to be
an actor on the stand i know that's what
we were just talking about
did you watch the alec baldwin interview
i did not
i don't i ca i'm not i'm not okay i
watched it okay
um and i think i just stand firm in
in what i've said previously he said he
didn't pull the trigger we got no
clarification on the interview of like
how exactly a woman died we got a lot
about what alec was feeling and how much
alec loves making a motion picture um we
got a lot of that
um
it's clear that i i do think this
situation has really [ __ ] with him and
so i don't i still
stand behind what i said like it's was a
horrible horrible accident
that i don't
think alec baldwin was responsible for
but he could be doing a hell of a lot
better job publicly
at being more respectful for the woman
who lost her life so what's the point of
the interview unclear so then and if
he's really i mean i would imagine if
something like this happens like it's
incredibly mentally disturbing right
what are you doing in an interview he's
really on nobody asked for and you're
still not giving answers you're giving
no answers you're really like making the
whole thing about yourself even though
we said at the beginning like i don't
want to make this i'm not the victim
here and i was like oh good
so then victim mentality like stop
putting yourself at the center of
everything i just didn't the interview
did nothing for me except
double down my feelings on thinking like
i wish he didn't do this i wish he would
act appropriately him and his whole
family like need to calm down a little
bit take some time out of the spotlight
stop doing interviews stop pulling over
on the side of the road to talk to tmz
because you're just making yourself look
bad and it's hella disrespectful to the
family of the woman who lost and like he
says that he's going through all this
mental anguish but then he acts in a
manner that doesn't represent that and
so actually he acts like he is losing
his mind like he really does he needs to
stop like i really find
i i'm struggling between like feeling
bad for him like oh my god what a
horrible thing to go through but then
also like really just having empathy for
the person who lost their life the
person who was shot
their family and like having to watch
alec baldwin like make this whole thing
about himself yeah
so
i i don't think it was a wise pr move i
don't think one thing he's done since
this incident has been wise i didn't see
anything that came out of the interview
that made me feel compelled to watch it
because it still felt like no answers
and just like this man crying the most
compelling thing was that he says he
didn't pull the trigger which like
makes no sense right no no but then just
explain like to how it went off right he
doesn't know so stop doing an interview
when you have no information and let the
police do their job yeah agreed
okay our next story's a little space
news a little specimen did you know that
michael strahan is going to space in a
few days i did know that and he's
revealing the personal items that he's
bringing to space like some sentimental
items he can only bring three pounds
worth of personal belongings so he chose
very carefully now here's what he's
bringing into space things that mean a
lot to him and then you can say like is
it going to be a jersey no it's really
like really sentimental and then you can
say like these things were in space
so he's going to take along 12 shell
casings from the 12 gun salute performed
at his father's funeral wow his super
bowl ring
his pro football hall of fame ring of
excellence and two watches wow
apocalypses are heavy yeah no
a pocket watch that belonged to his
maternal grand father
a rare timepiece with a celestial face
and a moon phase function okay a lot of
uh
watches
and he'll also bring up a pearl necklace
from his girlfriend's late grandmother
oh that's so sweet so so sweet not to
make everything about myself but then
i'm thinking like what was that
i have nothing of value it's like
sentimental value like in my home well
you would i think you would bring some
toast merch oh it'd have to be really
light i'd bring a toast pop socket yeah
and i would also bring i think a little
podcasting equipment podcasting from
space no of course no okay i could think
of a million things for my business but
like i don't really have like
like if i had like something from daddy
like i don't have anything what would i
bring
yeah i guess i have like a watch
yeah you have to think about it nope see
like it's nice michael strahan like
keeps things like i don't have anything
yeah i'm trying to think like any awards
you could bring your um
you won that gift of life
i could also bring my shorty award i one
once won from a fan number one and
snitches awards and she made jackie like
a full blown oh [ __ ] i forgot to bring
you something i was wondering if the
gifts were starting up again from your
tour i got a bunch of gifts on tour
which i loved but
someone came to a show and she was like
this is my aunt sue and aunt sue was
so [ __ ] cute and she was like i'm the
oldest person here i'm like literally
every person over the age of 30 says
that like you're not the oldest person
here she's like well i'm a librarian
then i have a gift for jackie and it was
so cute she gave this envelope and i did
like rifle through it before i threw it
in my suitcase um and she told me she
had a book a list of books that she
thinks she would like during the rest of
your pregnancy and just like for the
future because she feels like you guys
have really similar um just vibes when
it comes to reading and then a little
baby gift it was a little bib it was so
cute i have it at the house i'll bring a
few tomorrow you told me about auntie
when you were on the road and i'm so
excited for her that was so it was such
a thoughtful gift i was like gonna cry
that's claudia that's so beautiful i
know
wow and so any other gifts that you got
this weekend that you would bring to
space um you know i get a lot of custom
tumblers like you know we have this one
at shopmorningtoast.com and the girl's
got a drink and someone gave me like
theo's mom theo's dad really cute i have
a lot of cups you could bring a lock of
theo's hair to space oh
well thea weighs about 20 pounds you go
on a strict diet here's the thing if i
lost 20 pounds do you think they would
let me bring theo to space that's so
interesting i wouldn't do that part of
yourself no for do i mean dew is
definitely worth my fupa dude probably
weighs the same amount as my fupa
you know it's so it makes you think like
a piece of jewelry yeah it makes you
think but i also can't believe michael
strahan's going to space in a few days
and then he's going to come back having
been a space man which one is he going
with
blue origin is that
jeff i think that's jeff i think it's
jeff too i had just recently heard about
this and i thought it was very cool you
know so funny makeup michael strahan is
just like the most popular guy loved no
like any time there's like an
opportunity like whether it's television
space they're like who's someone that
everyone likes and it's like michael
strand you know he must be just like a
lovely guy personally because people
just want to give him these
opportunities you know
he must be just like nice yeah i'm sure
he's a pleasure to go to space with he's
a pleasure
so and if and maybe this will be a trend
of like other celebs is he doing the one
like the 25 minute
yeah i i mean i don't think he's moving
up there i think it will just be like a
popping in and out say you've been to
space that's cool he must be so nervous
i i mean yeah what kind of prep you
think you have to do like for your body
i think a lot i watched a trailer for um
a space documentary and there's a lot of
things oh a trailer wow yeah just the
trailer and it just taught me that
there's a lot that goes into going to
space yeah you have to learn well i mean
if it's a 25-minute ride probably maybe
he could hold his bladder yeah you do
have to learn how to like pee and poop
in space and all these things pooping in
space must be so weird like the second
the poop comes out of your butt like it
goes floating above your head i think
you have to poop into like a
cylinder a tube or a bag or something
smelly stressful yeah being an astronaut
is like all fun and games until you have
to take a dump
oh i know like being astronauts all fun
and games until you get your period yeah
and i think also for women it's much
harder to pick to pee in space than it
is for men oh just like on a road trip
any road trip just like literally life
day to day yeah you know there's a lot
of personal hygiene things i don't think
i can get on board with how do you put a
tampon in space without it like floating
away yeah i think maybe if you're on
your period you can go which is just
like
misogynistic yeah or you could as part
of space prep like you know get on some
sort of cycle
no there's like a there's a thing on
tick tock
remember when nasa sent a woman to space
for only six days
with 100 tampons they sent a woman to
space with a hundred tampons for six
days i have to be honest like
that's a little extreme but like that's
what i would need if i was going to
space on my period no it would be so
uncomfortable with every time i put in a
tampon it's like gotta take it out put
in another one yeah no because it's
constantly defying gravity and you know
what does your period flow down if
you're in space that's true like it
would come out your throat
because of gravity
that's disgusting
[Laughter]
i'm crying it's something to think about
we need to have a space a female space
expert we really do to ask these tough
questions yes but it's very much a thing
i think people have asked these
questions because i've seen like you
know things that are fun people are
curious fun facts about women in space
but you could also you know like get on
uh birth control or something and make
sure that right right that you're not
going to have your period yeah no it's
just like there's too many i have too
many bodily issues to really take the
chance and go to space like what if i
react weird to some space food and like
have diarrhea you know yeah i just i'm
not comfortable with that and then
you're like with other people and well
i'm sure you have to train your body to
space food before you go right right you
know they they think about those things
yeah that's true
so
yeah interesting
huh are you ready for our fifth and
final story
it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
okay who bleed out their mouth
it's gravity
it's a beautiful thing
okay tasha adams broke her silence on
her split with zach on the men tell all
stage last night she said quote i'm
heartbroken
so tasha spoke out after calling off her
engagement to fiance zach clark nearly
one year after the proposal between the
two of them aired
so caitlyn noted that tasha wasn't
wearing her engagement ring tasha said
quote all i have to say is that i'm
heartbroken but we really tried hard and
i still love him very much and i'm not
sure what the future holds you know how
it is it's really tough
kaitlyn responded i sadly do know how it
is it's really hard but we're here for
you and obviously want you to be happy
then tasha walked off while they brought
on one of the suitors um she just like
needed a minute and then she came back
and joined the show because they are the
hosts right which is their final time
right i didn't even put together that um
we were going to see her and she was
going to have to address that me too
because i'm so like not in on what's
going on in bachelor nation i just love
tasha i don't know what happened in the
relationship but i'm 100 on her side and
yeah this is sad but like i just want
her to get over it so we can start like
shipping her with other people
yeah i think it's going to take some
time and i'm sure like having to go on
live tv like
it's like annoying to talk about it when
you're probably not even ready yeah and
i don't know what and it also feels like
maybe this is just me being hopeful but
like maybe they could get back together
you never
we don't know what happened between them
so maybe it's just like things weren't
working they needed a break yeah that's
possible but just like little mix
sometimes break it's not good yeah but
also sometimes if you're announcing your
break like that's
that's the final right i think that if
you were really just actually taking
like a month off from each other just to
see where you landed you wouldn't make
the full announcement and stop your
engagement right not when so many people
have so much invested in your
relationship right or your band right
or your band so just love to tasha die
for her
yeah hope she's doing well
i'm sure she is
me as well and if you want more
bachelorette content head over to the
snatcher she has a new episode of the
snatcherette men tell all up now and you
get to catch up with the snitch which is
such a fun thing to do it's so exciting
the life of snitch the life of that
would be her reality show name yeah
and then everyone will be tweeting about
it tlos tea loss and log
um okay well those were the past five
and i definitely feel as though you
needed to know them i agree i feel like
you guys are in a good spot i feel
satiated
um but the show's not over because it's
tuesday and that means it's dear
toasters which is our advice segment so
if you ever want to write in to us it's
deertoasters gmail.com
let us know um what's going on you can
keep it anonymous we will protect your
identity at all costs and also if you've
written into us recently and we've given
giving you some wise sage advice did you
go with it did you not go with it and
give us an update
so the deer toaster segment is brought
to you by skylight frame which people
have been messaging me non-stop asking
for the code so skylight frame is the
photo frame you can update instantly by
email or from anywhere else it's a great
way to feel close to those you love even
when you're separated and it's super
easy to set up in under 60 seconds plug
it in use the touch screen to connect to
the wi-fi and enjoy sending photos to
skylight frames is effortless so you
give this the frame to your grandma and
then you're a million miles away on your
phone emailing to the frame updating new
photos for graham and then you'd be like
graham look new photos and then she goes
over and she thinks you're a magician
it's perfect for everyone in the family
you can just email them the email the
photos to your personal skylight email
address and they pop up in seconds so
people can send photos to the frame it's
a great way to keep large networks of
friends and families in touch it comes
in a black frame and a white mat so it
looks like a real photo frame that adds
a beautiful touch to your home it has a
gorgeous 10 inch touchscreen you can
swipe through photos with your finger
and even tap to thank the person who
sent the photo so it's the holiday
season this is an amazing gift for
someone you love someone you're related
to someone you don't see very much if
they live in a different part of the
country it's really a great gift and
they have 100 satisfaction guaranteed so
if you don't love the skylight they'll
offer you a full refund um
okay here's the offer listen because
everyone's been messaging me you can get
10 off your purchase of a skylight frame
when you go to skylightframe.com and
enter code toast so that's ten dollars
off your purchase of a skylight frame
when you go to skylightframe.com with
code toast that's s k y l i g h t f r a
m e dot com promo code toast
wonderful all right dear toasters dear
claudia jackie theo little bubba and
bruno
long time listener first time writing in
i'm writing in for my friend who's about
to get married in eight months she's
having a quick engagement because her
fiance has a job where he's where he's
gone for weeks at a time i don't think
eight months is a quaking me neither i
think it's a perfect amount of time she
asked one of her friends to be maid of
honor i'm a bridesmaid but her friend
currently lives in new york city and we
live in the south where the wedding is
this has caused some logistic issues for
planning wedding stuff already even
where she hasn't been available to help
my friend plan her wedding because she
has a really busy job two of the
bridesmaids are lawyers including myself
and we all have busy jobs
so that's annoying to me my friend has
been
my friend has been relying on the other
bridesmaids who live in the same city to
help her plan everything my friends
beyonce is out of town for her job
and she feels like she has to plan this
wedding on her own and her maid of honor
has essentially left her high and dry i
think my friend finally hit her breaking
point with her made of honor when she
complained about having to share an
airbnb house with eight bedrooms with
the bridal party after my friend had
already paid for it because she didn't
want to have to share space for two
nights with the wedding party she also
said she couldn't have the bachelorette
party on one weekend we can all go
because it's the weekend after her
boyfriend's birthday and they might go
somewhere she hasn't taken any steps to
plan the bachelorette either or connect
with the bridesmaids so we can help plan
my friend is now regretting making her
her maid of honor should she say
something or should she just preserve
the friendship and let it go until after
the wedding okay so i'm like feeling
like are we responding to the bride
right now or to the bride's friend we're
responding to the bride's friend who is
not the maid of honor but he's like
acting like the maid of honor is the
maid of honor no i know but i feel like
this is a issue that the bride should be
having so she wants to know what advice
should i give the bride right because we
are the vessel in which is the bride
asking for advice like it doesn't seem
like she is no i feel like maybe she is
like i do feel like by the end i said
should she say something so yeah i guess
i'm gonna go with the fact that like you
told her you know what we're having this
issue i'm gonna write into my favorite
podcast they're gonna tell us what to do
a hundred percent fire the maid of honor
but not like just be like you obviously
seem so busy i don't want to be more
stressed on your already busy life i'm
just going to have someone else be the
maid of honor i love you no no shade i'm
being just it'll be better for both of
us 100 percent
maybe don't even have someone else be
the maid of honor maybe go no mate of
honor because otherwise like that could
cause friction and also then you're like
promoting it's just like becomes a bit
of inciting so maybe just be like listen
i i didn't realize what the role
entailed and i think i'm putting too
much on your plate when i can handle it
and some of the girls down south can
handle it too so
you are relieved of your duties like i
love you do not worry about it i'm not
mad i'm not mad like oh
but this is off your plate and just act
like you're on you act like you're doing
her favor yeah that's a really good idea
act like she asked and then like the the
friends who live down by you who have
been like going out of their way to try
and plan
you you have to make them the maid of
honor just be like i'm now bestowing
these responsibilities onto you because
these girls seem eager to help like the
girl who wrote in no and neither of us
had maid of honors and
everyone like pitched in with their you
know specialty i don't know but like
weddings in the south are like very
traditional and a maid of honor is like
an important task like you hold the
rings i don't know what you do but no
but it's like an important thing but in
terms of like planning the bachelorette
party and stuff but i think it's like
you need someone like in name to have
that title
i i don't think that you do i think that
this is something that
you can
part with me too it's like a little
immature
yeah you're moving like you tried it
didn't work out
no need to like cause political
infighting with the other bridesmaids
just to have a maid of honor to say that
you had a maid of honor yeah and you
know what this is when it's like just so
easy to have a sister because obviously
even if you have the best friend in the
whole world your maid of honor is always
going to be your sister so like it's
like a scapegoat yeah i agree so and
then also i think that the bride is
gonna have to pick up some of the slack
but i don't think that's a bad thing no
one's gonna be as invested in your
bachelorette party as you like i feel
like for our bachelor parties we did
prime like i planned like the i remember
doing like finding everyone's schedule
because like also i'm close with
everyone who's coming right you're the
center of the group right so we really
and then we can do it we can go exactly
where i want to go and then everybody
you know brings the shirts and brings
the merch and like that's the energy
vibes and and that worked and i think it
makes it a little bit
less painful for everyone like and less
and painful for you like no one knows
what you want for your bachelorette
party better than you yeah and when
other people have to not only like pay
for the trip and go on the trip and
spend the time but they also have to
like plan it and maybe they get it wrong
like i think you can alleviate
everyone's burden and get the exact trip
that you're looking for i agree
i think it's all good me too don't sweat
it don't sweat it's really not a big
deal yeah and you're the bride so
everyone has to be nice too 100 it
sounds like you have good friends who
are writing into a great podcast on your
behalf i'm not friends with taste
friends with taste all right next up hey
claudia and jackie long time listener
and lover of the podcast so my question
slash issue is one of my best friends
has these parties for the holidays
memorial day labor day new year's etc
and each time she hosts a party she puts
out a jar requesting donations for the
food that she provided at the party
which is like hamburgers hot dogs chips
pasta salad nothing so crazy
her and her husband also requests it to
be byob also we're in our early 30s and
they both have pretty well paying jobs
usually no one puts any money into the
jar and she gets really upset should i
tell her that no one contributes
anything because it's [ __ ] tacky as
hell or should i just say nothing any
thoughts and opinions would be great
love you guys you make my day better by
doing what you do and congratulations
jackie i'm about to have my first baby
girl in a few weeks sincerely an
anti-contribution party goer that is
wild when you first started sharing this
i was like wow how cool to be the girl
who always has a party like you know how
nice to be a friend of that girl who
always has something to do with the
label
this is the hostess with the leastest
like i just want to say there are two
very different things
this tip jar is so insane i think byob
actually is a nice thing like you're
alleviating something for the host
alcohol is expensive if everyone just
brings one bottle i don't think that's a
big deal when i have a party i ask
everyone i'm like please bring a bottle
of tequila i'm never gonna and it's like
i will have some for sure but bring more
i don't want to have to like buy a
million cases and then like people might
not drink it yep and also bring what you
like i like a little by oatmeal me too
but you can also like have nothing no
you gotta have like the base but in the
hopes that pretty much everyone brings a
bottle of whatever they're going to
drink so that you know exactly that
everyone's covered with what they want
yeah i think that's totally fair and
actually a better way to throw a party
especially at this age like everyone can
afford i've never heard at a tip jar a
contribution jar for a party to help
offset the cost because it's like
then don't have a party that's awful i'm
sorry like
that's really bad no one's like asking
you to have a party and if you can't
swing it then that's totally fine
no i've never heard of that i've never
heard of that i don't know that i would
say something because like it takes a
big set of balls to put out a jar like
that yeah and i don't think it's
something that she hasn't thought
through and and felt like she wanted to
be that person
well she made that decision and she has
to sleep at night just make sure like
that no one is contributing you please
don't ever feel compelled to contribute
yeah and you have to say anything like
you know just reap all the benefits you
now have a party to go to every new
year's every labor day it's nice
and and maybe you know in a few years of
no contribution she'll get the message
right right
the silence will be deafening
that's insane that's a really kind of
bizarre
i've never heard of that i've never
heard of that because don't throw a
party
if you don't
like when you throw a party and you're
like a host you're really doing it for
the love of the people you want them to
all enjoy themselves
not
for any sort of like financial reason
like because if you if you
if you need financial help then you
shouldn't be throwing them before you
throw whatever party is within your
means there's all different kinds of
parties right
so i'm just
and i and you know what if you're
throwing a party and you want to offset
some of the costs like you can do like a
potluck like there are ways to be like
tacky without being so tacky like there
are ways to just take things off your
plate like oh can someone bring dessert
yeah oh i've got everything covered but
someone can just pick up some sodas like
there are ways the tip jars just like
kind of obvious and tacky yeah no it's
like we're all doing you a favor by
coming
yeah i'm good and now yeah very bizarre
and then it's like if if everyone starts
paying for the parties that they go to
then then the next person who has a
party should get
you have to pay them no and then if
people start paying for the parties they
go to we'll say well i don't want hot
dogs i want macaroni and cheese 100
so it's just a slippery slope do not put
anything in the tip jar but also don't
say anything just let her like embarrass
herself
in her own way okay
here's the final one yeah hello ladies
first of all i listen to the podcast
every day and i love you guys jackie
congratulations on your pregnancy being
a mama is so special thank you i give
birth to a precious little girl in
september and as a push present my
husband is having a band made with
sapphires her birthstone i was so
excited about this super sentimental
gift and so i sent a picture to my mom
of the rendering of what my new wedding
stack would look like fast forward to
today we were talking about what
everyone wants for christmas and my mom
says that she's asked to have a band
made with blue stones to go with her
wedding bands i literally thought it was
a joke i have a great relationship with
my mom and she's an amazing grandmother
she's always copied things i've done
like wearing some of my clothes from
high school buying the same running
shoes having the same home decor buying
the same designer purses that i have and
she even copied my perfume last year
i've always thought it was a little cute
but a little annoying so i've never said
anything besides little comments here
and there but now i can't help but feel
like copying this is a step too far
i tried to give her ideas of other ways
she can celebrate her grandkids with a
pendant bracelets even different kind of
ring but after 30 minutes of trying she
to gently talk her into something
different she said she really wanted the
ring and my dad was going to get it for
her i really want this to be my special
thing and having her matching one with
having her have a matching one will
really bother me i don't want to be a
bratty daughter who [ __ ] at her mom
for copying her but what do i do
it's kind of weird so
funny
i don't know it's like cute yeah it's
not like that big of a deal i know and
but and it's i feel like this
toaster like is
has a good attitude about it in general
because it's clearly like a theme a
thing but this is just one thing that
has gone too far for her and she's
trying to put her foot down and it's
just not working so i really don't
i don't know what to tell you other than
to just maybe be honest about your
feelings not like maybe a pendant maybe
just be like listen this is something
that like i want just for myself like i
love when we twin but i just want this
one thing yeah you have to go be mine
you have to either go all the way like
just ignore it or be communicative you
can't be like murky in the middle yeah
no and like just be honest about your
feeling as opposed to like trying to
dupe her into wanting something else but
also know it seems like your mom loves
you so much like when you if you do
communicate it with her like she'll be
really hurt
so just think is it worth it
because this is not an ill-intended
thing it's very sweet yeah it's
overstepping boundaries but it's really
sweet it is it is sweet and also then i
don't want her to get the wrong idea
like that she can never copy you again
like on the running shoes and stuff
because it's like cute it's so cute and
it doesn't seem like it bothers you at
all like i just can't relate because
nothing i do or any of the ideas that i
have is are like creative enough or cool
enough for people to copy like i'm
always copying you i'm always copying
other people um so i think that if
someone did this for me like i would be
so unbelievably flattered that they like
liked something that i came up with so i
can't relate to it but i i can see how
it's annoying i agree it just it really
for me would depend on who's copying me
like
someone
yes but like if it's someone that like i
love so much like anyone in the family
and they were helping me i'd be like so
flattered yeah truly serious form
battery but if it was someone who like
stopped copying me yeah yeah you know
like some people just like get under
your skin yeah no and it's like
especially when p
it yeah it just depends on the person
but it seems like in most respects here
like it's it's a really sweet thing but
i understand wanting this one you're
allowed to like you know have your
boundaries i would try being honest yeah
and then let us know how that goes yeah
um honesty is the best policy for the
most part
depends on the dear toasters thank you
guys for writing in again if you have
written into us recently and you have
some sort of update for us on how the
situation unfolded if you took our
advice we would absolutely love to hear
from you send that to your toasters
gmail.com and any other issues you want
us to read that's every tuesday dear
toasters gmail.com and that is our show
our show no one else
could be confusing thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places wherever
you listen to podcasts five nights a
morning chose to leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are and if you made it to the
end of this episode thank you so much
for actually listening to the end
because your true toaster who values our
opinion and we obviously have to do the
blood emoji um on our instagram so go
drop that emoji on our instagram let us
know you made it to this entire episode
and you really appreciated the canon
conversation about menstruation in space
have a great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow i'm in space from
what